i play nick terela
okay let's uh
let's play knight f3 this game
okay d5
playing the ready
c4
yeah actually i don't i don't know that
line very well i was i had some vague
memories because i used to play
this but i never
i had that variation something similar
to that in a couple of games a long time
ago
one of the games i ended up down a piece
but i ended up winning actually against
the gm
so it was
lucky
see it was completely winning but
um
similar position
yeah the b5 i remember the b5 they
should be five idea but other than that
i didn't
exactly know what i was doing there
either
trying to sort it out as i was going
so go to a cattle and close catalan
i guess queen knight c3 queen c2 and
then bringing the rooks to the center
and playing e4 is the
the way to go from here
the idea that when black tries to free
himself my pieces will be better placed
queen c7 i don't like the queen on the c
file is poorly placed
i will play rook c1 and she won't be
able to stay there forever
so yeah the late uh alex white kevich
was very good in these kinds of
positions as white
usually black instead of queen c7 play
some v6 bishop b7 and
um
finding a spot for the queen is also a
problem though in this line for black
okay i don't know what the plan is with
knight f8
i don't know what the idea is
but i will just keep making my moves
rook c1
eventually e4
[Music]
okay i mean the knight is not well
placed here it's dominated by the g pawn
so i'm not sure what the purpose of
bringing the knight there was
e5 is not going to happen let me just
continue with my
build up
if i take on d5 at some point i free his
light squared bishop i don't want to do
that
so but still the queen in the long run
even if i don't immediately open see if
i will not be able to stay on there so
now it looks like it's time to play e4
although i could
now take on d5 because i have because of
this move b6 if he takes with the e pawn
i have knight b5
but he can actually then move his queen
and if i take on c6 and he has bishop d7
so that doesn't look like let's just
play e4 looks like it's time to do this
so he
doesn't react but now
because of the position of the queen
there could be some additional problems
for black
or i could go e5 and
h4 h5
so cd he can take with a c pawn
and
i don't think i achieved too much i mean
i have or e5 first let's say and then cd
and if he takes with his c pawn
knight b5 he trades queens and then he
gets
rooked f to c8
i can then take on c8 and if he takes
with a rook i can take on a7 but then he
might go rook a8 and then take on a2
so let me just i i don't really like
releasing the tension in that way let me
just build up
instead is here it's so hard for him to
play c5
uh well
knight t7
he might be threatening to take on c4
and c5
and then i could probably play d5 though
so i don't think he can take on e5
so knight e7 yeah i can also still take
d5 go for that line
knight b5 takes takes rook to c8
rook c1
take 6 a6
doesn't lead anywhere
so let me play h4
i don't think he's threatening c5
ever
with his queen on that he can take on c4
and then i take back and then c5 h5
followed by
d5
and i doubt he can take the pawn on e5
hard time with oh by the way what's time
to draw it's long time control you have
a hard time with closed positions as i
find the moves arbitrating
that's interesting yeah
it's uh
it can be a problem
if you're very concrete you have a very
concrete style of played and
figuring out what to do in a closed
position can be tough but here for
instance
this pawn is now with this knight here
this is a pretty big weakness so there's
going to be some queenie two only thing
is his main counter play is to take and
play c5 at some point
and i usually want to be responding with
d5 but now i'm
i think i want to release the tension
finally cd and then go queen e2 and here
i'll be threatening his
to attack his queen with if he takes to
the c point if he takes the e pawn i
like this chain this structure then i
have a huge majority on the king side i
also have the move e6 which would
destroy his position
most likely
so now queenie two and my idea is to go
knight g5 i also threatened to to attack
his queen and i might have
such moves as knight b5 also coming out
says queen has to go i don't know
d8 probably
queen d8
and then not knight g5 but maybe just
knight h2 and take his h pawn
that that seems like it should be enough
just take his h pawn i'm up a pawn and
then
and then i
um
then further move my queen and start
pushing my h pawn with an attack on his
king
now that move allows me to just take on
d5
especially because if he tries to
sacrifice his queen i have an in-between
check on e7
okay so now i don't really want to take
on e7 because
then it allows his knight back in
so i i think i
have knight c7 rook f8
and
my knight gets a little bit funny
although i do get to play d5 then
i don't particularly want to yeah okay
let's just go knight e3
yeah
no let's go knight c7 and then d5
i want to open up the game i want this
bishop to be introduced to g7
start start uh two
so i want to play after rook moves i'll
play d5 maybe then follow up if he takes
it with e6 even
which looks like a quick win
so now positions opened up it starts to
look concrete but before you see that i
just i put my pieces where
i think that they will they will be
useful in the future and
um
prevent black's counterplay breaks which
was
c5 primarily but
well he made it so
so that it would be harder for him
himself to make the pawn break because
he put his queen on c7 which was a
mistake so he actually did my work for
me a little bit
okay that rook's not running away so i i
don't
need to
take it immediately
but
yeah
knight g5 is a possibility
don't want to trade to light scored
bishops but i most likely have to
but knight g5 young well let's just take
this
let's just take the rook
and now i can i could go
knight g5
let's just go knight g5
probably trade um trades on on g2
i'm threatening h5
so yeah
he's not going to get a knight here if
somehow he could bring his knight to d5
well i'll
make sure to prevent that
then he would have some compensation
91 was okay also possible because then i
would take the knight that's a good idea
actually would have been take with the
knight on
g2 and then the knight would come to
some good square like f4 or e3
so that in this position like
rga said
knight e1 but of course knight g5 is
also fine
and just up the exchange and he has to
play g6 but now it looks like i can
probably just check made him on the h
file eventually
with g4
coming up
h5 oh sorry no it's his move yeah
he has to play g6
okay he checked here i don't even really
want to trade queens anymore of course i
could i could go queen f3 and then my
rook will invade
i'll come to think of it that's probably
the simplest way to do it
i don't need to be dealing with this
g4 stuff i just go rook c7 and
if he goes knight g6 trying to bring it
to e7 and then to d5
i will have bishop a3
and he wants b5 maybe i should have well
i like you know
i have rook c6 um
he wants to play b5 knight b6 yeah but
i'm going to prevent that
i don't want the knight on d5 not that i
wouldn't be winning in that case but
i it would it would be more difficult
and it also just wouldn't be
wouldn't be what you want here
so here now now i can play d5 but it
lets his
yeah i'll just go d5
and
his knights are tripping over each other
so there's no knight e6 move
ever
you get both hooks into oh whoops
what am i
and i thought that wasn't possible but
he scared me there for a second
yeah
um
of course even if i had hung the
exchange
it still would have
been winning for white but
um
should be two
okay black is making some kind of random
moves
so yeah
might be eight okay it looks like i can
now
in him and i wish i could have got g6 in
first but that's uh fine
just make another queen
or
a new queen
so yeah
black is apparently going to play on
until mate
this that's his prerogative
it's only a few moves though so that's
okay
okay good game